it's great to welcome to the program
today Jason Goldwater who is a
California attorney who represents small
and medium sized businesses throughout
Southern California advises businesses
unemployment and labor issues and best
practices adjacent great to have you on
today thanks David great to be here
so let's start with in figuring out you
know every day we hear this number of
billions of dollars is going out
everybody's getting 1200 bucks
unemployment's being boosted by $600 the
Paycheck protection plan billions and
billions and billions of dollars are
going out let's start talking through
what's been announced and what has
happened so the 1200 dollars were close
to two out of the three weeks that they
said it would take for that money to
start going out is there any system yet
for people who did not get direct
deposit of their tax returns last year
to say here's how you get me my money
are any of these infrastructures in
place at this point so they are not the
IRS has said that they are going to
create a portal on their website where
people can essentially go on and say I
want my money going to this bank account
or going to this address so that has not
happened yet even though the private
sector could probably do this in under a
day
the IRS I'd be very surprised if they
managed to do it by next week and don't
forget it's not just people who didn't
receive direct deposit but maybe people
whose bank account information has
changed whose addresses have changed so
none of that infrastructure is in place
and like I said I'd be very surprised
that that happens by next week I think
probably one to two months is more
likely so two weeks ago they said in
three weeks the people who have the same
direct deposit information as when they
filed their tax returns would start
getting their $1200 the people who need
to as you say provide banking
information might have had a change of
address etc it could be three more weeks
that sounds like you're saying it's all
a little bit optimistic right now
well alright I mean unless the IRS is
going to start blindly sending out
$1,200 to bank accounts at that you know
just because something was correct on
their 2018 tax return doesn't mean that
bank account is
effect could be clothes I mean they
could be sending $1,200 really to bank
account that's not open to someone
else's bank account so I don't see how
this is going to happen unless people
first have a chance to confirm that the
information the IRS has is still correct
from the information the IRS had
potentially a year and a half ago okay
so now let's talk about the the
supplemented of the the both bolstered
boosted unemployment the idea was
unemployment ways of course managed at
the state level Massachusetts has its
system Illinois has its system etc there
are different state level benefits that
are the maximum benefits available to
people the federal government announced
they would be supplementing those
benefits with up to $600 per week in
additional funding now I know a lot of
people who have been who filed for
unemployment in the last three weeks a
16 million people did they as of now are
not getting anything additional above
and beyond what the state provides what
do we know about the rollout of that so
as you just mentioned everything is
occurring on a state-by-state basis all
I can tell you is there's very there's
very little information actually about
what is happening we know that there is
supposed to be this additional $600 we
don't know when it's going to be
implemented as you mentioned each state
has a different system and on top of
that the cares Act also provided that
people who are self-employed independent
contractors for example getting economy
workers would also be eligible for
unemployment assistance now typically if
someone is self-employed or an
independent contractor there's typically
a voluntary unemployment insurance
program that they can pay into to be
eligible so the cares Act does away with
that but the problem is there is not a
single state yet as far as I'm aware
that is implemented guidance as to how
exactly this program will work for
people in the gig economy for example
people who are self-employed and who is
eligible and how they're going to get
their money and right now the guidance
essentially is for people to go ahead
and apply and
try to figure it out later and of course
it is important for people to get
applications in because the applications
we will be processed in the order that
they're received and they will not get
the unemployment insurance until
essentially for a period before they
applied so I know some people in the
Midwest who you know there's a lot of
states in the Midwest that have they
don't have very robust unemployment
systems so they are maxing out sometimes
at 350 dollars a week they're counting
on that extra 600 that the federal
government says is coming and it's not
there and they're not getting any
answers from the state unemployment
departments as to when that's going to
start yeah I mean California I can tell
you maxes out at $450 per week so you
can just think with our cost of living
in San Francisco and Los Angeles in San
Diego for 50 a week does not go very far
at all
and you're absolutely right that the
sixth additional $600 is absolutely
critical but the state employment
offices are used to processing a certain
number of applications per week and as
the new point of that we've had an
additional 50 and 60 million people
applying for unemployment and the
infrastructure is just not there to
process those kinds of numbers so let's
now oh sorry go ahead yeah digestion
there is one thing I wanted to mention
the lot of people are not aware of so
this varies state by state but a lot of
people who are underemployed right now
who have had their hours cut may be
eligible for unemployment assistance
again depending on the state depending
on what they're earning level is
currently so it's important for people
who are underemployed who've had their
hours cut to go ahead and apply for
unemployment insurance as well so then
we've got the programs for businesses
and part of this is the payment
protection plan there's a couple of
other programs and elements to these
programs that are available every day
I'm sorry what was that elements of
medical elements of medical yes elements
elements of funding so every day at a
press briefing mike pence or donald
trump will say something like
you know a million people have applied
or three thousand lenders are now taking
applications or we have processed 10
billion dollars every day it's different
and the terminology being used is
different our business is actually
getting money yet have businesses
received any money yet under that
program so I am not aware personally of
any businesses that have received money
under the Paycheck protection program or
the emergency consuming economic injury
disaster loan program so that doesn't
mean it hasn't happened that just
doesn't it just means that the rollout
has not been very widespread there are
still some banks like Citibank which is
my bank that are not even accepting
applications and the money is already
going to run out
I mean Bank of America on its own I
think as of a few days ago they process
I think over twenty percent of the total
funding available for the PPP program
meanwhile Citibank is not even accepting
applications so the whole again the
rollout here has been unfortunately a
little bungled
it's increasingly seeming to me and I
again I hope that things can get
reopened sooner than later as is safe
never beyond what is safe but I hope
things get going as soon as as safe it's
starting to seem like a lot of these
funds may not even get to people before
the reopening starts if things continue
on this path yeah I mean you know it's
not just a question of reopening but but
by the time we're through with the
lockdown frankly there will be so much
job loss and unfortunately the job loss
really is not just affecting at this
point the hospitality industries or the
restaurant industries or economic
industries but it's affecting all the
other industries and directly I mean I
can tell you as a lawyer for example the
courts are closed so any lawyers were in
litigation have no work right now
even though they did businesses
really want to be spending money on
lawyers I mean this is affecting every
segment every segment of society right
now in the last bit of time we have is
there anything we have not talked about
either in terms of programs or in terms
of what individuals can or should be
doing that you think is important for
people to know so I did want to talk
briefly about the programs that are
available because there have been some
changes to the program since they were
initially announced so the first program
that's available is the economic injury
disaster loan grant so the the bill said
and the Small Business Administration
initially said that these were going to
be $10,000 grants so the SBA has now
changed that now it's going to be $1,000
grant per employee that the business
employs up to $10,000 so you can imagine
a lot of small businesses may only be
getting one or two thousand dollars for
example those loans were supposed to be
processed in three days I don't know of
any I mean the link the application has
been up probably for a week and a half
or two weeks and I don't know anyone
who's gotten that yeah you can't apply
directly for that on the SBA website if
you google SBA kovat 19 the second part
of that is the Paycheck protection plan
so that provides up to two and a half
months of payroll and it's a loan and 1%
now initially it was 0.5 percent now
it's 1% but the loan can be forgiven if
75% or more of the proceeds of the loan
are spent on payroll and your payroll
does not decrease and individual banks
are the ones processing those
applications and then the third
component are just ordinary Small
Business Administration loans are called
780 loans and for new loans that are
issue the Small Business Administration
has pledged to pay 6 months of principal
and interest on those loans and
eventually you could get you could get a
loan that might be a two-year loan and
in the first six months the that those
payments would be made for you and you
would not need to make that up
correct so theoretically you could pay
the principal back after six months -
the the principal
have already been made on your behalf
and you would not end up owing any money
at all and of course this is if you can
actually get the money disbursed which
seems to be a question mark around all
of these programs right now yeah I mean
I'll tell you that the ordinary SBA
loans are a little easier to get just
because banks make more money on that
the interest rates are substantially
higher than the people he loans and so
banks although the difference with the
7a loans is that the banks do assume
some risk on that I usually from 25 to
50% or so so banks may be more reluctant
and probably will be more reluctant to
issue those loans right now we will
continue keeping an eye on it and of
course as important as the small
business programs the individual
programs unemployment and the $1200
deposits which we are continuing to try
to erase the question marks around but
question mark certainly remain Jason
Goldwater's a California attorney a
Jason thanks so much for talking to us
and and explaining all of these
different elements
thank you David better luck to you